Kate Upton opens up about her sexual  harassment allegations against guests  co-founder Paul Marciano the 25 year old  model is now detailing claims she made  against the former CEO of guests last  month on Twitter in a new extremely  candid interview with Time magazine Kate  alleges Paul began harassing her and  quote forcibly grabbing her breasts  during her first professional modeling  campaign with the company when she was  18 years old she tells the mag Paul used  his power to make me feel insecure and  powerless and says I'm not going to let  him intimidate me anymore  I'm sick of being silenced and expected  to sweep everything under the rug Paul  maintains he's innocent  calling Upton's accusations absolutely  false and releasing this statement to  time I have never been alone with Kate  Upton I have never touched her  inappropriately nor would I ever refer  to a guest model in such a derogatory  manner